OK, let's unpack this.
Have you ever had that nagging
feeling, even when you're
completely alone or you know in
a crowd that you're being
observed not necessarily by a
person, but by something unseen?
Or maybe you've sensed these
unspoken rules, like invisible
boundaries that you just know
not to cross, but nobody ever
actually spells them out.
That feeling, yeah, that subtle
unease.
Exactly the feeling that you're
living your life, making
choices, expressing opinions,
maybe even, you know, getting
away with some minor
transgression.
But there's this, this unseen
observer taking notes.
Well, what's truly fascinating
here is how the source interior
we're looking at today suggests
this isn't just a feeling you
know, or some fleeting
intuition.
It's presented as a deeply
embedded systemic reality.
Systemic.
How so?
Today, we're embarking on a deep
dive into, frankly, an alarming
perspective that paints a
picture of a nation operating
under a pervasive invisible
surveillance mechanism, a system
designed not merely to observe,
but to actively conditioned
behavior on a national scale.
The material describes America
as what it actually terms a
shock collar state with an
invisible fence.
A shock collar state.
OK, so our mission today is to
thoroughly explore how this
alleged system operates, right?
We need to delve into its
surprisingly deep historical
roots.
Which are quite extensive, as
we'll see.
Understand how our everyday
technology becomes an integral
part of its fabric and examine
why, according to these sources,
we might even be well complicit
in its ongoing perpetuation.
That's a key point they raise.
We're going to pull apart the
claims that virtually every
action, every thought, every
flicker of descent is
meticulously recorded and
permanently filed away.
It's an unflinching look into
what the sources call America's
invisible shock collar.
Let's.
Get into it.
So let's jump right into what
the material describes as this
pervasive, invisible net.
The central, frankly astonishing
assertion is that literally
every public action you take,
whether you realize it or not,
is being recorded and filed.
That's a key assertion,
absolutely.
The core claim is incredibly
sweeping.
Every protest you've ever
attended, every sign you may be
waved, every chant you've
shouted in public, every tiny
flicker of what the sources term
righteous descent, It's all
supposedly being scraped up,
indexed, time stamped, and
stashed in a dossier with your
name on.
It indexed and time stamped OK.
And what's particularly
emphasized is that it doesn't
matter if you were arrested or
not.
It doesn't matter if you
genuinely believed you were
engaging in civil disobedience
or simply participating in some,
you know, harmless St.
Theatre.
Or just venting maybe?
Or just venting, or expressing a
kind of performative rebellion
that you maybe never gave a
second thought to afterward.
The material suggests all of it
contributes to this this
accumulating record.
This is where it starts to get
really interesting, isn't it?
The material contends that it's
irrelevant whether you labeled
it civil disobedience or
harmless St. theatre.
It's all recorded.
Yeah, but the scope extends far
beyond just public protests.
It reportedly delves into what
you choose to wear or even not
wear, right.
Like, for instance, the material
really points to donning a pussy
hat or a balaclava, A Meiji hat
or a rainbow flag draped over
your shoulders.
Things people use to signal
identity.
Exactly.
Even something as seemingly
innocuous as your hoodie is
claimed to make you a target and
and what the sources refer to as
a post COVID society wearing a
mask could mark you.
Which is interesting.
Just as not wearing a mask
during the height of the
pandemic was also said to make
you a target, it repeats this
picture of constant sort of low
level behavioral assessment.
So you're damned if you do,
damned if you don't.
Almost.
In some contexts, according to
this analysis, yes.
What's absolutely crucial to
grasp here is the implication
that this is not a temporary or
transient measure.
It's not just for emergencies.
Not at all.
The sources explicitly state
that the technology spun up and
normalized in the name of public
health or public safety or
border security never switches
off.
It just waits.
That's chilling.
It suggests a permanent, ever
active system, constantly
testing your boundaries when you
believe you're invisible,
watching precisely how you
behave when you assume you're
getting away with something.
It's a mechanism that is
perpetually online, perpetually
collecting data on everyone,
building an ongoing behavioral
profile.
And it's not confined to just
visible public acts, right?
The sources also delve into what
they describe as more mundane
transgressions.
Yes, absolutely.
Think for a moment about every
store you might have been
allowed to loot, as they put it,
or every petty act of vandalism
you perhaps thought you got away
with.
Consider every instance where
you felt the system simply
shrugged and let you off with no
bond, or maybe no trial, or
perhaps blamed it on a District
Attorney seen as soft on crime,
right.
Every cash register you might
have hopped.
Every self checkout scanner you
managed to skate through without
paying.
Every moment you told yourself
you were too insignificant to be
noticed.
You thought you were invisible.
The sources claim you were
noticed.
The phrasing is stark.
The House took notes.
The house took notes.
Wow.
OK, this leads us to a truly
evocative and frankly unsettling
metaphor used in the source
material America as the mansion
of bait.
It's a powerful image if you
envision America as this immense
mansion.
The sources explained that every
unlocked door, every Rolex left
out on a hallway table, every
$100 bills sticking out of a
purse, every temptation, it was
bait.
It was a test.
Bait, not just carelessness.
Deliberate bait.
According to this view, the
powerful implication here is
that these opportunities for
minor transgressions, these
moments of perceived freedom or
slight malfeasance, aren't mere
oversights or coincidences.
They're presented as deliberate
setups.
To see what you'll do.
Precisely.
The material posits that every
time you cracked open the liquor
cabinet and congratulated
yourself for getting away with
it, the walls were watching the
walls.
Don't forget.
This suggests A fundamental
design, A pervasive system
engineered specifically to
expose character flaws, moral
weaknesses, and a willingness to
bend OR break rules when given
the opportunity.
And to really drive that
chilling point home, the sources
lean heavily into the familiar
Willy Wonka analogy, don't they?
They do, and it's quite
detailed.
The Chocolate Factory in this
context isn't just a magical
place, it's portrayed as a
perfect candy colored
panopticon.
A panopticon like the prison
design where the guard can see
everyone.
Exactly.
The entire factory itself is
conceptualized as a mansion of
bait, where every hallway, every
tunnel, every fantastical room
is in fact a carefully
constructed test.
So the kids aren't just lucky
winners.
According to this analogy, no.
Each child with a golden ticket
is under the illusion that
they've won some random lottery
based on pure hearted luck, but
each room is designed to expose
exactly what they can't resist.
OK, give us an example.
Well, take a Gustus gloop for
instance.
He finds a river of chocolate
described as deep enough to
drown him.
Which plays right into his
gluttony.
Precisely.
It directly exposes and exploits
his weakness.
Violet Beauregard discovers A
forbidden piece of gum, chews.
It turns into a blueberry Freak,
starkly revealing her
impulsiveness and disregard for
rules.
Right, she couldn't resist.
Then there's Veruca Salt.
She encounters an army of
trained squirrels and a mountain
of shiny treasures, all
meticulously placed to, as the
sources put it, beg her to prove
how rotten she is with greed.
And even Grandpa Joe.
Even Grandpa Joe.
He initially seems like the
moral chaperone, right?
But he succumbs to temptation
with the fizzy lifting drink.
The analysis suggests these
weren't accidents.
They were precisely the point,
each scenario designed to reveal
an inherent weakness.
And Wonka himself, he doesn't
really do anything directly,
does he?
That's the key observation in
the analogy.
Wonka never has to raise his
voice, never has to physically
intervene or shove anyone
through a trapdoor.
He simply stands back, hands
folded.
While the Oompa Loompas handle
it.
While the factory's hidden
cameras, which are brilliantly
conceptual as the Oompa Loompas,
perform their true function,
recording every moral slip,
every greedy impulse, every rule
break.
So the Oompa Loompas aren't just
singing elves.
They're portrayed as a Stasi in
bright overalls and almost
comically sinister force,
operating in a Deutsche
Democratic Republic of Moral
Theater, singing their
cautionary lessons while
simultaneously filing away every
observation.
A Stasi.
Wow.
The entire factory then becomes
an expansive open air bait box,
systematically cattle living
every child's weakness and
laying bare every parent's
failure.
OK, so how does this connect
back to the bigger picture of
America?
The transition is made
remarkably clear in the sources.
The material states.
You walk in thinking you're
special.
You leave as proof.
You can't help but break the
rules when the walls feel sweet
enough.
Wonka's factory is the American
mansion.
The only difference is there's
no golden ticket.
You're already inside.
We're already inside.
That's potent.
This analogy powerfully
illustrates the core concept,
constant observation and a
system explicitly designed to
tempt and then record behavior
not for immediate punishment,
but for future leverage.
Which brings us directly to this
really unsettling concept
introduced by the sources, what
they call a shadow rap sheet or
permanent crime insurance.
Right.
This is crucial.
It's not about immediate arrest
or conventional prosecution.
This is something else.
It's about a persistent,
invisible and deeply personal
file that follows you.
The sources described this as an
invisible file, a shadow rap
sheet, or a pseudo rap sheet
that meticulously logs every
antisocial behavior you
performed when you thought you
were free.
Antisocial behavior like.
What?
Well, it allegedly includes a
wide range of actions, from
instances of looting a
convenience store to do Donuts
at 3:00 AM in a city
intersection, punching out your
roommate, bullying someone on
video.
Things people might post online
themselves.
Even exactly, Or even bragging
about a sexual assault you were
convinced would never come back
to haunt you.
Now, in older era, such actions
might lead to a local police
report visible, often limited in
scope and duration.
Right, something formal.
But the pseudo rap sheet is
portrayed as far worse.
It's invisible, it functions as
soft leverage, it reportedly
never expires, and, crucially,
it doesn't even require a judge
or any formal legal proceeding
to be activated.
No, judge.
So who activates it?
How?
This immediately raises A
profound question.
If these files are indeed
invisible and perpetual, what
does that signify for our
fundamental understanding of
innocence or the very
possibility of redemption?
It suggests A pervasive,
constant state of being observed
where every past action,
regardless of its legal
consequence at the time, can
perpetually be held over you,
ready to be deployed as leverage
later.
Just waiting.
It's depicted as sitting there,
waiting for that precise moment
when an individual reaches a
certain level of influence or
accumulation of assets, or
simply possesses a mortgage or a
government job or an office to
run for, or an opinion worth
silencing.
When you become inconvenient.
That's the implication.
It's characterized as permanent
crime insurance for the system,
ensuring that if you ever pose
any significant threat, the
pseudo offense gets triggered
and you learn the jolt all over.
Again, the jolt, like the shock
collar.
Exactly.
It's not presented as pre crime
in the traditional predictive
sense where they try to stop
something before it happens.
It's framed more as a highly
sophisticated system of pre
leverage.
Your past actions aren't just
archived, they are meticulously
catalogued and stored
specifically to be weaponized at
the most opportune time.
So they want the data on your
past behavior.
The material contends that the
state wants to precisely map the
map of your character when you
think no one is watching.
Every social flashpoint, every
moral candy you grab from the
Mansion of Bait gets scooped up,
meticulously mapped to your
name, and tagged for later
retrieval.
It sounds exhaustive.
It's a system, according to this
analysis, that simply never
forgets, creating a digital
shadow that constantly trails
you.
OK, moving on.
It becomes clear that this isn't
merely about old school
surveillance tactics.
The well known Broken Windows
theory seems to have undergone A
profound digital transformation.
Precisely.
The sources draw a Direct Line
connecting the contemporary
surveillance state to the long
standing broken windows theory.
You know, the sociological idea
that cracking down on minor
crimes like graffiti or broken
windows prevents larger decay
and more serious criminal
activity.
Giuliani's New York, that sort
of thing.
Right.
But the analysis argues that
this Old Street level logic
didn't die with urban decay in
Giuliani's New York.
It just went digital.
How so?
It's the same principle.
It's the very same mindset and
underlying philosophy, according
to the sources, but applied on a
vastly different and
unprecedented scale.
So if we connect these ideas,
what does this all mean for us?
The seemingly minor acts of
dissent or even petty crimes
aren't just about immediate law
enforcement responses.
No, they're fundamentally about
data collection on a truly
massive scale.
The sources state unequivocally
that Broken Windows policing
laid the moral groundwork for
the PRISM dragnet.
Same mindset, new scale.
Wow, Prism, that's a big
connection.
It effectively cultivated a
public appetite, they argue, for
surveillance that never switches
off.
The old version, the theory
would essentially say stop the
graffiti, stop the murders.
Cause and effect.
Right.
The new digitally adapted
version, according to this
analysis, effectively says hunt
the memes, hunt the chatter,
hunt the moral crack before they
break open.
It's about preemptive behavioral
intervention through data.
Hunting memes, so online
activity is key here.
Absolutely.
And the truly ingenious and
unsettling twist here, as put
forth by the sources, is that
the bait never disappears.
Mansion is always open.
Every perceived opportunity for
a minor transgression, every
open liquor cabinet, every easy
window smash, every riot with 0
bail is designed to feed into
this same invisible file.
The core objective, according to
the material, is to observe and
document who you are when the
social contract phrase.
When things get chaotic.
Exactly.
They want to know who you
betray, who you scapegoat, who
you loot alongside, and who you
docks.
When you think you're righteous,
the sources claim, you might
think you're merely breaking
windows.
But they're breaking you.
They're breaking you, mapping
you, archiving you.
The petty crime in this
framework becomes the on ramp to
total coverage, and the cheap
moral panic at the street level
becomes the very justification
for transforming the entire
country into a cold case waiting
for better tech.
Waiting for better tech that
connects to the data storage
idea.
Precisely.
And this transition to digital,
this transformation of the
surveillance landscape, is
powered by an astonishing
proliferation of everyday
technology, much of it found
right in our homes.
Yeah, you mentioned this
earlier.
The sources assert that since
around 2020 especially, the
entire place has been rewired
with technology, things we use
constantly, often without a
second.
Thought it's what specifically
your.
Nest camera, your Ring doorbell,
your grocery store loyalty car,
your phone microphone, your
smart TV.
They're all described as
becoming part of the same
perimeter now.
Part of the fence.
Part of the invisible fence,
yes.
And it's not just their
presence.
All this personal data,
regardless of how seemingly
innocuous it might appear on its
own, gets atomized and
recombined, hoovered into data
centers you'll never see,
governed by algorithms that
outlive any president.
OK.
Let's break that down a bit.
Atomized and recombined?
What does that actually mean in
practice?
Well, think about it.
When your Ring doorbell records
video, it often uploads it to
cloud servers, right?
And in some documented cases,
that footage could be shared
with law enforcement either
directly or indirectly, often
without a warrant.
We've seen stories about that.
Your smart TV, beyond simply
displaying content, often has
built in microphones and
cameras, tracking not just your
viewing habits but potentially
listening to your conversations.
Which is creepy.
And your grocery store loyalty
card tracks every single
purchase, building an incredibly
detailed tell profile of your
habits, health, even financial
status.
All of this, the sources
suggest, get atomized, broken
down into minute data points,
and then recombined through
advanced algorithms to to
construct comprehensive,
evolving profiles.
So it's the connections they
make between the data points.
Exactly.
This sophisticated digital
system, the analysis argues,
effectively replaces physical
barriers by wiring boundaries
directly into people's minds,
the sources bluntly state.
The fence isn't a metaphor, it's
a protocol.
It's a set of rules, an
operational procedure.
Yes, a set of rules that governs
the invisible digital
boundaries.
This immediately connects to
what the source is called the
cold case analogy for a
perpetual data storage.
It's a truly unsettling thought,
isn't it?
Comparing our digital footprint
to forensic evidence that never
degrades.
It is indeed.
The sources illuminate this
concept by drawing a parallel to
how law enforcement handles
physical evidence.
They explained there was a time
when a mere drop of blood at a
crime scene meant almost nothing
beyond perhaps a blood type.
Before DNA testing.
Exactly.
Yet forensic departments
rigorously kept those lab slides
in freezers for decades, waiting
for the day the science caught
up the advent of DNA analysis.
A murder case from 1975 doesn't
remain a purely 1975 case when
it's reopened in 2025 with
groundbreaking new technology.
The old evidence becomes new
again.
The old dormant evidence
suddenly becomes critically
actionable.
OK.
So, applying this principle to
our digital data, what does that
look like?
It paints a rather chilling
picture of the future.
Every petty crime, every riot,
every antisocial outburst you
think you got away with in 2020
sits in that freezer, your
personal evidence locker.
My personal evidence locker.
Wow.
The core idea is that with the
rapid advancement of
technologies like quantum
computing and next Gen. pattern
recognition, things that are
maybe just on the horizon now
for.
Coming fast.
Coming fast, the fence will
close like it was built
yesterday.
Nothing stays cold forever.
So beta collected now could be
used against you decades later
with tech we can't even conceive
of.
That's the argument.
The sources offer a stark
example.
A man who thought he framed his
buddy for a crime in 1975 and
walked free for decades, only to
be summoned back to the gallows
when the data catches up.
The fundamental difference now,
according to this analysis, is
that you can't burn the evidence
because it lives everywhere.
It's duplicated, distributed,
and perpetually accessible.
O If we connect this to the
bigger picture, it introduces
this profound concept of digital
immortality for your actions,
doesn't it?
It really does.
It's not just about what can be
done with the data now with
current processing power, it's
about what future unimagined
technologies will enable with
the immense volume of data being
collected today.
A.
Long game.
The argument is that the true
game, the ultimate objective,
lies in the archive itself.
The sheer ability to freeze your
past actions in place to be re
evaluated and potentially
weaponized 1020 or even 50 years
from now for something you did
when you genuinely believe the
system had moved on and
forgotten.
And it seems the system isn't
just passively collecting data
and archiving it, it's
reportedly actively scoring us.
The sources use the striking
analogy of an ancient Egyptian
mossit scale.
Yes, the material describes this
system as actively scoring you
everyday.
It's based on a continuous
aggregation of keywords and
mundane actions stacked up until
your soul cross the threshold.
Your soul.
That's heavy.
Metaphorically speaking, yes.
The idea is that a certain
threshold, say 5 petty crimes,
10 moral cracks, 1 flag riot,
amounts to enough weight and you
become a specific target for
deeper scrutiny or intervention.
Like a demerit system but
invisible.
Exactly.
The source is powerfully drawn,
the analogy of the ancient
Egyptian scale of mat, where
your heart was weighed against
the feather of truth to
determine your fate in the
afterlife.
Right, I remember that heavy
heart.
You get devoured.
In this modern context, Anubis,
the God of the underworld, is
replaced by a black budget
program and the feather of truth
by an algorithm.
If your heart and symbolically
speaking, is deemed heavy with
enough betrayal and antisocial
behavior, the implication is
that you get devoured.
Metaphorically devoured,
presumably.
Targeted, leveraged,
neutralized.
Perhaps if it remains light, you
pass for now.
The absolutely crucial point,
emphasized by the sources, is
that this scale never goes away.
It just keeps counting one moral
infraction at a time, until you
forget what you were ever
innocent of.
Constantly accumulating, always
being evaluated.
Always evaluating, always
accumulating, constantly shaping
your invisible score.
That's a chilling thought.
Let's delve now into what the
sources present as the core
mechanism of control in this
system, behavioral conditioning.
The material describes America
not as a traditional prison with
visible bars, but is something
far more subtle and insidious, a
shock collar state.
That's a truly powerful and
disturbing distinction made by
the sources.
They unequivocally claim this
country doesn't need prison bars
and iron fences to keep you in
line.
It's a shock collar and an
invisible fence, exactly like
you'd use for a dog or
livestock.
Like for a dog.
Wow.
The argument is that instead of
expending vast resources on
building ugly visible physical
walls, the system chooses to
wire the boundaries into your
head, effectively creating
mental rather than material
barriers.
And there's a clean here, almost
brutally pragmatic economic
rationale behind this, isn't
there?
The the sheer logistics?
Oh.
Absolutely.
The logistics of physically
controlling 340 million
Americans with a relatively
small force of perhaps 4 to 5
million law enforcement and
military personnel are presented
as impossible.
The numbers, as the sources put
it, simply don't pencil out.
You can't watch everyone all the
time.
You literally cannot post a
soldier on every street corner
or wiretap every whispered
conversation in real time.
So the alternative, they argue,
is to train the population to do
the policing, the self
surveillance for themselves.
Turn everyone into into wardens.
Exactly.
The material suggests that the
design of this system
effectively transforms everyone
into an unpaid warden, a snitch,
A moral informant.
You are, in essence, taught to
perceive fences and patrols that
don't physically exist.
You imagine the boundaries.
And while the shot caller is
metaphorically kept on
everyone's necks, the more
insidious step is that you wire
the fence into their skulls,
making the control internal.
This, the sources contend,
gradually creates a form of
collective Stockholm syndrome,
where the populace begins to
identify with or even defend the
very system that invisibly
controls.
Them OK, let's really unpack
this.
The genius here, if one can call
it that it's disturbing, is the
radical shift from overt visible
control to covert, internally
driven self-control.
It's about making you your own
jailer.
Precisely.
The sources elaborate on the
power of the jolt, that
momentary, unpleasant reminder
of the boundary.
You test the system once,
perhaps twice, and when you feel
that metaphorical jolt, you
quickly learn where the edges
are.
Like a dog learning the edge of
the yard.
Just like that.
After that initial conditioning,
the ZAP isn't even necessary.
You see it put out of habit.
Out of habit, not even fear
necessary.
This profound conditioning
means, according to the sources,
that every day you wake up and
measure your worth in the eyes
of the hive, the moral points,
the lines you dare cross, the
small materials that keep you
safe.
The Hive constantly assessing
yourself.
The implication is that every
protest, every riot, every petty
crime is bait to see how you
manage yourself when you think
you're invisible.
It's designed to make you
internalize the boundaries so
completely that you come to
inhabit this open air prison so
intimately the people start
defending the walls they can't
even see.
Defending the walls they can't
see, that's powerful.
The true math, as they argue, is
that you don't have to pay 4
million people to chase 340
million if you can successfully
engineer the 340 million to
chase themselves.
The sources take this concept
even further, describing this
pervasive system as nothing less
than livestock management.
Livestock management and
behavioral conditioning at a
national scale, refined through
decades of Pavlovian loops.
That's the explicit terminology
used.
Pavlovian loops like
conditioning responses through
repetition.
And this is precisely where the
illusion of freedom becomes
critical.
The material states you're given
the illusion of freedom and told
the First Amendment is sacred,
but the moment you act like you
believe it without the script,
the file opens, the footage
runs, the blackmail writes
itself.
Without the script meaning off
the approved narrative.
That seems to be the
implication.
The sources draw a direct and
unsettling historical parallel
to what was done to Martin
Luther King Junior decades
before any of this digital
panopticon even existed.
How so?
They didn't arrest him outright
for dissent, at least not
always.
Instead, intelligence agencies
meticulously tracked him.
They hoarded every affair, every
rumor, every hotel room
rendezvous they could use to
blow up his credibility if he
ever stepped too far out of
line.
Kompromat, basically.
Essentially, yes.
And crucially, they didn't burn
that file.
They kept it as a persistent
source of potential leverage.
And the sources claim this same
principle works now, only scaled
up to everybody.
That's the argument.
It's particularly effective,
they argue, on a younger
demographic, noting that a huge
chunk of the population under 26
is so consistently busy filming
themselves documenting their
lives.
Social media constant
documentation.
That they don't even realize the
raw footage is the leash, the
very material being used to
build these files.
The footage is the leash.
The analysis states, rather
cynically, that an undercooked
frontal cortex is a beautiful
thing for the ones who run the
machine.
They allow you to test the
fence.
They give you the sensation of
being free.
Let you run wild for a bit.
They even permit you to run
wild, brag about the date rapes,
the carjackings, the petty
violence, the weekend you
smashed up a target.
And often there are no immediate
charges, no follow up, just.
The file.
Growing just an invisible file
that sits there waiting for the
day you have a mortgage or a
government job or an office to
run for, or an opinion worth
silencing.
This isn't presented as pre
crime as we discussed earlier.
Right, it's pre leverage.
It's permanent crime insurance.
The collar, though hidden, is
reportedly on everyone all the
same.
What's striking is that these
ideas aren't entirely new or
rooted solely in modern
technology.
The sources suggest that none of
this is tinfoil, meaning these
concepts of behavioral control
have surprisingly deep
historical roots in U.S.
government programs.
That's a crucial underpinning of
the sources argument.
They vehemently stress that the
US government and its
contractors have tested, studied
and run live experiments on
population behavior for
generations.
Generations.
Wow, like what kind of programs?
Well, the material details
several specific historical
programs, beginning with the
Stanford Research Institute, or
Sri.
This was described as a Cold War
hub for what is now commonly
referred to as behavioral
engineering.
Behavioral engineering sounds
ominous.
They engage in explicit testing
of phenomena like how crowds
respond to a planted rumor, how
they react to staged conflict,
and how easily they'll scapegoat
an enemy by feeding them moral
panic, the sources flatly state
they wrote the manuals for.
It they wrote the playbook.
These were not abstract
theories, but concrete applied
methodologies.
Then, of course, there's the
infamous M cultra.
Yes, the CIALSD experiments.
A very real CIA program that
explored how substances like
LSD, hypnosis, blackmail, and
various forms of psychological
torture could break or rewire a
mind.
These methods, alarmingly, were
tested on prisoners, patients,
students, people who never
volunteered.
Unethical, to say the least.
Deeply and beyond Bicultra, the
sources cite other equally
concerning programs like
Operation Chaos, Operation
Bluebird, and Artichoke, all
presented as examples of
concerted efforts aimed at
cracking identity,
comprehensively mapping the
human mind, and even testing
whether ideology could be
implanted, erased, or
overridden.
Trying to fundamentally alter
people.
That appears to have been part
of the exploration, yes.
What's fascinating here is how
these historical examples aren't
just isolated anomalies.
The sources portray them as
foundational architectural
blueprints that didn't simply
disappear after the Cold War or
public outcry, but instead
profoundly evolved.
Evolved into what?
Well, consider COINTELPRO, the
FBI's domestic
counterintelligence program.
The material vividly describes
it as a behavior experiment
turned weapon.
It wasn't simply about gathering
facts or intelligence.
Its methods extended to active
measures like seating paranoia
within target groups,
disseminating forged letters,
actively spreading DIS info to
turn allies on each other, and
even blackmailing leaders with
sexual dirt.
So active sabotage.
Active sabotage and
psychological warfare, Yes.
The core objective according to
this analysis was not mass
arrest.
It was to keep people so divided
and discredited that the public
would self police any real
threat to the status quo.
Self police.
There's that theme again.
Exactly.
The extensive files amassed by J
Edgar Hoover during his tenure
at the FBI are presented as the
primitive version of the shadow
rap sheet we discussed earlier,
Laying the ground and work for
what was to come.
OK, so this extensive, deeply
ingrained architecture of
surveillance and behavioral
influence, as the sources
emphatically claim, didn't just
vanish with the end of these
specific programs.
It transformed.
It underwent A profound and
transformative evolution.
The material asserts that all of
that architecture didn't
disappear.
It got privatized, digitized,
scaled and sold back to the
public.
Sold back to us.
In the form of behavioral
analytics, threat assessment,
predictive policing, and
national security profiling
terms we hear all the time now.
Right, they sound almost mundane
now.
The dramatic shift, according to
the sources, is that what used
to take a team of operatives,
now it takes an API call to
Amazon's recognition or
Palantir's Foundry platform.
OK, explain API call again.
It's essentially a request from
one computer program to another.
It allows automated systems to
access and process fast amounts
of data much faster and more
efficiently than human agents
ever could.
Amazon's Recognition, for
example, is a powerful facial
recognition service.
Used by law enforcement
sometimes.
Yes, and Palantir's Foundry
platform is renowned for its
data integration and analysis
capabilities used by government
agencies and corporations
worldwide.
The sources are quite stark
here.
The fence isn't a metaphor, it's
a protocol, and you are already
inside the test.
Inside the test, this
illustrates a clear,
uninterrupted continuity and
modernization of the
surveillance approach then.
That's the core argument.
This evolution brings us
directly to the more
contemporary systems that many
of us are at least vaguely
familiar with, like Echelon and
Prism.
But the sources seem to suggest
these are almost quaint now.
That's a fair characterization
of the sources perspective.
Yes, they contrast these older
systems.
Echelon, for instance, was a
global signals intelligence
program primarily run by the
Five Eyes Alliance, the USUK,
Canada, Australia, New Zealand
intelligence sharing group.
Its focus was largely on
scooping up international phone
calls and faxes.
Then came Prism, which gained
notoriety post 911, a system
that flagged directly into the
data streams of major US tech
firms like Google, Microsoft and
Yahoo.
Snowden revealed a lot about.
That he did.
And while these operations were
framed as lawful interception,
the data Hoover, as the sources
describe it, was bottomless.
So if we consider all of this,
what does it truly mean for our
lives?
Snowden, as the sources grimly
point out, showed the world the
taps were never really turned
off.
And the NSA's construction of
that enormous Utah data center
in Bluffdale, housing billions
of gigabytes of raw signals,
becomes chillingly relevant in
this context.
All that storage capacity.
The sources particularly
emphasize the idea that metadata
is the message.
It's not just the content of
your communications, but who you
called, when, where you were.
That's the outline of your life,
the patterns, the patterns.
And the cold case analogy
applies here, too.
All the metadata you generated
when you thought you were
beneath the radar, the looting,
the doxing, the petty riots, it
all sits there, cold, stored,
waiting for quantum computing
and predictive analysis powerful
enough to reprocess it like a
fresh file.
It feels inescapable.
The conclusion drawn is that
what was once the exclusive
realm of spy thrillers is now
streamlined, automated, and
profoundly integrated into our
everyday digital lives, often
without our conscious
realization.
It's one thing for such an
expansive system to exist, but
the sources introduce a truly
unsettling point.
Why do people not only tolerate
it, but in some ways even desire
it?
That's maybe the most disturbing
part of the analysis.
It seems to be rooted in the
idea that every tribe wants the
caller when it serves them.
This race is a truly fundamental
and unsettling question.
If, as the sources suggest, this
pervasive machine feeds itself
on our righteousness and anger,
how do we even begin to question
its existence, let alone
dismantle it, when we are all to
some degree invested in its
operation against the other
side?
Because we want it used against
them.
Exactly.
The sources explicitly detail
this phenomenon, stating that
the right wants it when it hunts
Antifa looters and anarchists.
Conversely, the left wants it
when it hunts January 6th
trespassers, online bigots and
real or imagined Nazis.
It cuts both ways then.
It's a striking indictment of
how partisan divisions can
inadvertently fuel the expansion
of such a system.
And it stretches even further
beyond those readily
identifiable political binaries,
doesn't it?
It does.
The analysis suggests that
border Hawks desire this system
for tracking migrants.
The so-called blue cities
reportedly want it for
monitoring rural militias, even
techno utopians.
People who believe tech solves
everything.
Proponents of technology as a
solution for societal ills are
portrayed as wanting it for
combating misinformation and
enhancing safety.
It paints a picture of an almost
universal human desire for
control.
Specifically control over the
other, whoever that other may
be.
So everyone wants control, just
pointed in their preferred
direction.
Precisely.
The sources deliver a blunt
conclusion.
Nobody wants the fence torn
down.
They just want to be the one
with the shock button in their
hand.
This, they claim, is the
fundamental reason why there is
no longer a robust party of
civil liberties or an ACLU with
teeth, as they phrase it.
Everyone, it seems, is too
preoccupied fighting over who
gets to sit in the control room
rather than challenging the
existence of the control room
itself.
What's also quite provocative
and counterintuitive in this
analysis is the argument that
major leaks, Snowden, WikiLeaks,
manning, things many might see
as blows against the system.
You'd think they'd weaken it.
Right.
Exactly.
But the sources argue they
actually serve to reinforce it.
How does that work?
The sources make a truly
audacious claim here that the
biggest leaks, the Snowden
archive, the WikiLeaks cables,
the Manning drop, didn't blow up
the machine at all.
They made you fear it more.
Fear it more?
They're not portrayed as genuine
disclosures aimed at dismantling
the system, but rather as
carefully orchestrated
inoculations or scarecrows.
They're depicted as the shot
caller buzzing in public, so you
learn to keep your head low in
private.
A public demonstration of power.
That's the argument these leaks
primarily serve to remind the
public that the system is always
on.
The chilling implication is that
the state or the system itself
has a vested interest in
allowing you to see the
monster's teeth once in a while.
Because, as the sources argue,
if these files and surveillance
capabilities stayed sealed and
invisible forever, the public
would eventually get too brave.
Complacent.
Perhaps.
Defiant.
So whether on purpose or by
accident or by design, these
leaks occur.
So you whisper to yourself at
night.
They can see everything.
It's presented as a master class
in psychological conditioning
through controlled exposure.
And they give a recent example,
right?
January 6th.
The quick identification and
roundup of more than 1000
January 6 trespassers is
presented as a prime recent
example of this principle in
action.
It was achieved not by hiding
the dragnet, but by explicitly
broadcasting it.
Showing their work, essentially.
Exactly.
They show the public the files,
the phone tower pings, the
doorbell camera footage, the
Google geofences.
This, the sources contend, was a
powerful behavioral reminder and
echo that if they can do it to
terrorists, they can do it to
you.
Making you think twice.
It's meticulously designed to
make you begin watching your own
edges to self police your words,
your direct messages, your
search history.
You essentially become your own
warden because the system has so
effectively taught you how and
why.
Finally, the sources suggest
that the system's immense tower
supply remains entirely uncut,
regardless of who occupies the
highest office.
It's almost independent of
politics.
Yes, the material starkly states
it doesn't matter which suit is
standing at the podium.
Donald Trump is the 45th and The
Sweeney 7th President of the
United States.
And yet the shock collar hums
away exactly the same, because
no president in living memory
has ever voluntarily cut its
power supply.
No one turns it off.
This suggests that the
surveillance apparatus is a
deeply entrenched, bipartisan,
self perpetuating system that
effortlessly outlives political
cycles and specific
administrations.
It's not dismantled or even
significantly reined in by new
leaders.
Rather, it is consistently
streamlined and adapted.
Made more efficient perhaps?
Perhaps it's enduring control is
in this view based on the
fundamental math of 340 million
people essentially training
themselves to stay put to self
regulate within the invisible
boundaries of this pervasive
system.
So what does this all mean for
us?
We've delved into how these
sources paint a truly unsettling
picture of America as an
intricately designed mansion of
bait, constantly logging our
behavior and meticulously
building a permanent, invisible
digital file on each of us.
A file that never goes away.
This isn't just about catching
criminals.
It's presented as a
sophisticated system of
livestock management and
behavioral conditioning that
encourages us to self police to
internalize the rules, even to
the point of defending the very
walls and fences we can't
physically see.
If we connect this to the bigger
picture, the sources suggest
that you, the individual
listener, are a test subject in
a maze that has no exit signs
anymore.
No exit signs.
They pose a truly profound and
unsettling question if the
system wants you to believe
you're hearing a warning, a
subtle jolt to keep you in line,
but you're also simultaneously
hearing a lullaby that gently
tucks you back inside the very
walls you vehemently swear you
can't see.
A lullaby that keeps you
compliant.
What does that imply for the
concept of true freedom, for
genuine independent thought, and
for the very nature of personal
autonomy in this digitally
pervasive age?
What stands out to you about
this deeply provocative
perspective on America's
invisible fence?